how strange I guess you can't have it
call Palm Springs if you don't have palm
trees it's Tim Schmoyer with the Hat our
first time meeting in person roberto
blake in the house friend of the channel
head of the plug about to go on an epic
rain i'm looking forward
[Music]
morning guys it is just past five
o'clock in the morning I am on my way to
a YouTube content called clan makan in
Palm Springs California and I'm going to
take you guys on my journey with me
[Music]
so climber Cana is a YouTube conference
that I love how long stood around for I
was invited to go by Tim Schmoyer who I
have a lot of respect for another
channel that can collapse together and I
don't usually go to conferences and what
I'm speaking mostly because the main
value point to a conference is the
networking and I don't really enjoy
networking I really think I want to get
better I mean there's not going on my
list
there's a bunch of people that I know
that are going who have virtually met
like Tim like roberto blake like antonio
bunch of people that I've met that I
know are going Solis is going to be a
good time with them
and we'll see what happens it was one of
those things where I felt like I didn't
need to go but I may regret not going I
want to know I'm okay with knowing and
failing I'm okay with knowing it not
working out and being away to a couple
days what I'm not okay with is wondering
she's a guy but if I went under ten we
get that feeling where you know you
might regret not doing it just go and do
it you can live with failure you can't
live with the regret of not knowing so
that's me that's clever con on my way to
Palm Springs
lots of fun
[Music]
landed in Chicago gotta hop my flight
now to Palm Springs
one of the things that I love doing on
airplanes when I run out of things to do
catching up on emails is I ever no file
so what people send me articles I found
an article that I want to read one of
the things I'll do is I'll clip it just
a bit later and then I'll load it
offline Evernote and is good there's a
bunch of articles that I haven't
although read for a while it's taped up
for myself to read finally got to check
them off my to-do list so that was fun
in Chicago it's raining hopefully it's
nice warm and sunny in Palm Springs
California
[Music]
so is on the fence whether they get a
Starbucks or not try to eat healthy but
then I saw this cappuccino new midnight
middle cut apathy I'm left oh oh my god
okay the users I have another person in
a while until coffee though I think it's
it's cream-based
oh my god the mint mmm it's like after
eight I'm a drink this isn't in Canada I
might I might end up having one of the
day name is I should be after but it's
really
[Music]
all right I made it look look what I see
when I come up this entrepreneur hunter
of the year I love it that was actually
a decent trip I decided to get Wi-Fi for
the first American forever ordered of Y
from the plane usually I get on the
plane in my email I'd read my articles
and then I'm not have stuff to do and
he'll watch the movie whatever but today
I decided I'm going to get Wi-Fi and I
was productive pretty much every single
minute so far the chip Rose either at
the airport OHS on Instagram just
sending messages to people thank you for
following me who look at this welcome to
Palm Spring look at that beautiful here
it's nice and warm and then on the
airplane I was watching the YouTube
videos prepping for next week for all
the videos done a lot of work done I'm
being really hard on the team that's too
good for that but I feel good because
for you guys the standards are going up
what kind of lipstick is the top ten
rising standards mean better video so
anyway I'm feeling good I feel like I
wouldn't waste a whole bunch of time in
the air traveling so I'm going to pop
over and get to the hotel I'm feeling
Compu ttle palm trees I'm strange I
guess you can't have it called Palm
Springs if you don't have palm trees and
it goes together alright let's do it
eggs it only no return ha ha I have to
walk across the street to get to where
Ober is allowed to pick you up but it's
beautiful here guys look look what I see
nice mountains palm trees water fountain
flowers kind of missing Nina right now
she'd be holding hands doing this
together she has a nine-to-five job so
she can only take so much time off I
love it
[Music]
I'm really glad I took my allergy
medication
smelly grass emerge the grass but
awesome oh so good
[Music]
all right I made it home for the next
couple days the Westin Mission Hill
let's go see inside I think I found tim
schmoyer friend of the channel youtuber
sunset claps are going to go the pricing
it's Tim Schmoyer its Tim Schmoyer with
the hat our first time meeting in person
you can see young man yes
all those good Tim when I meet pretty
much every week in online mastermind
group that he started so it's always fun
to meet people in person and so just
meet another computer I'm excited I'm
going to go find my my room and my my
room and I get checked in five thirty
five times a Carmichael for the next
three days looks like that's pretty nice
master bedroom got some coffee look at
the bathroom looks nice
I approve going to unpack and it is what
130 right now and the first reception
pool party intro the people the two so
I'm going to go hang out there Tim
offered introducing people my general
strategy with these kinds of things is
since I don't go up and talk to people I
will often just bring a computer or have
my phone and sit down
in a public place and chilled or work
and then people recognize me and come up
in start conversations so that's my plan
we'll see how it goes I don't know why
but the first thing I do when I check
into a hotel in the US that turn on CNN
I never watch scene in at home I don't
know why it just feels like I'm
traveling and I need to put on the CNN
it's a tradition alright had a shower
change my shirt
that totally different shirt right you
guys totally help different shirts going
to go check in apparently they have some
other stuff happening people are just
still starting to arrive and so we'll
see today's most each is about reading
people the next day hanging out by the
pool if I don't tell anybody else work
on some videos to you guys and then the
conference actually searches tomorrow so
let's check in see what happened here to
pick up some swag got a t-shirt cup and
cashew almond top you have any of these
and there's some love are they again I'm
sorry they're cricket so she leave lying
crickets gonna give a lovely I might
come back for later but for now are they
all pregnant yeah Oh barbecue meal worms
I don't know about that this is Ricky
Ricky what's up fast what's your
favorite video all about to be honest I
mean I wake up every morning and I'm
like a popular expert so I had you know
the marketing one that just said just
watch a marketing one just 111 which is
a youtuber to we're going to we're going
to chat afterwards we're going to chat
after I grab my crickets time to eat
worth the season screw I don't this is
dinner for lunch
dinner guests have been shining with
chilling within their yes sir where I'm
weird like time zone differences three
hours behind this is lunch okay what's
for lunch there is chicken Fettuccine
but Tim disorders it's crazy this is a
pineapple inside the burger that's crazy
I recommend come back and get that next
time I'm gonna just video with video
employ to your son what are we talking
about we're talking about your one word
brain talk about online video I'm
looking forward in this video I
interview Evan Carmichael on his tips
for how to stand out on your YouTube
channel through branding YouTube
algorithm hacks and how to make more
money on your YouTube channel through
strategic brand deals so far so good fun
event lots of people inside think
youtubers nobody's really blogging or
filming so I don't want to be the
disguiser psychos everybody next step
mom I don't want a video by little bit
we're going to we're going to I'm going
to head back to Tim's room for a private
interview
for video creators go check that out
actually when is when is it when is I
was going to go live I have no idea okay
this will go live before change so go
check out James channel at some point
for this interview a couple weeks this
is Tim's setup pretty impressive Senate
have once and me to set up for this
cameras bigger than mine but how you use
it look at that I feel like a winner
today yes that's how I'm greeted when it
comes to Tim's home Tim's home so as a
fun interview with Tim we'll see when it
comes up hopefully that done now there's
a hors d'oeuvre
Arthur's in the background basically
came out saying hi doesn't drink
[Music]
definitely gotta grab some guacamole
Roberto Blake in the house friend of the
channel friend of the book about to go
on an epic ring oh God
doing that okay great and as a but like
I'm talking to Karen like actually like
doing on handlebars on another zombie
along to be great for both the entire
club outside and etic was like wow I'm
talking about expected like none of us
are entitled is someone you admire God
it is a five-carbon older horse and and
sometimes a byproduct of circumstances
they had no control over that were very
fortuitous
I don't want hot pepper whatever it is
like you wanted to happen it's written
what happens with you working perfect
you can't have the expectation that just
because we worked hard that anyway
severe look like if it doesn't like
what's in it for them like I think no
one believes anymore
like what for the other person are they
getting interaction because I think many
people thought about weapons for the
other person takes learn something
everything that he became very dramatic
difference entitlement showed up into
our heart with your heart with respect
Iran fire showing up to work heart and
my heart on the kids still met that I
could get heads or closely work as a
going to taste the intern but every but
I wasn't in positive that someone like
I'm more concerned anyone
no no I got first place slightly 32nd
back lowers my last race I was lost that
a breath has a lot of silver will be in
80 acres and be 20 seconds bathroom they
win and the 30 seconds slow
oh hi part of Lake so that was a lot
more fun than anticipated so I can find
my way
it's what what's 1:30 or so in the
morning Toronto time we kind of closed
the party had some good conversations I
can't see me I went dark and had a good
chunk of time with with Charlie from
charisma on command we had met on email
but hadn't connected in person and so we
connected it had some good business talk
Damon is girlfriend Jessica good good
people so ended up closing down the show
talking entrepreneurship it's good it's
good
a lot of a lot of you here like family
bloggers not a lot of connection to what
I do but Charlie and Antonio Roberta
wouldn't in the group so I'm going to
get ready for bed the downside wise I
think it to say good night to mean us so
I miss that kind of sad about it but
we're going to have breakfast tomorrow
and eat then head off for a fun day of
whatever we're doing tomorrow so I'm
back clicking on CNN yeah get ready for
bed and I'll see you tomorrow